what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to the room around up our
weekly series where we cover all the
news and rumors that you may have missed
over the course of the week and
technically it's wednesday but i'm going
out of town this weekend for my sister's
birthday i'm taking her to the newport
aquarium so maybe i'll bump into some of
you guys there somewhere but i won't be
here so hopefully between now and sunday
we don't miss some gigantic piece of
news where andrew garfield comes out and
says hey everybody i am actually going
to be in spider-man and here's
everything that's going to happen in the
movie hopefully that doesn't happen
it's pretty extreme example but you guys
get what i mean so let's get into our
news and start talking about what's
happening out there in the world so
first things first one of the big
questions a lot of you guys have been
asking is when is venom going to meet
spider-man when are we going to finally
get tom hardy meeting tom holland and
we'll get hard holland hanging out
together that sounds messed up but we'll
get those characters crossing over in a
movie so some good and bad news on this
the good news venom director andy circus
came out and said that venom is going to
meet tom hardy's spider-man the bad news
we don't know when
he literally said
at some point and honestly i understand
his rationale here the stance he took is
that if they just had venom meet
spider-man right now that's kind of the
big event right that's the big thing
everybody wants to see admittedly the
venom movies have been really really
good at least the first one was really
really good i know i didn't get the best
reception ever but i enjoyed the first
movie the second one i'm looking forward
to but spider-man's got a lot of major
villains there's a lot of anticipation
for the sinister six at least some
variation of it in the marvel cinematic
universe during spider-man no way home
potentially even in doctor strange too
or the future of the mcu and there are
villains out there that we haven't seen
hide nor hair of in any form or fashion
in any of the movies that have been made
about spider-man chameleon craven the
hunter are just a couple of those
chameleons especially interesting
because that's the first villain that
spider-man ever fought in the history of
his comic book publishing so the fact
that we haven't seen him seems a little
strange to me but andy circus took the
approach and said there's a lot of
stories to tell about a lot of villains
out there and the fight between
spider-man and venom is so anticipated
we can save that because if we end up
introducing a lot of these villains and
there's a good reception for them we
might be able to find some way to work
them in and i'm down for that right as
much as i would love to see a fight
between spider-man and venom not gonna
lie i would kind of love to see venom on
the sinister six
and see like a symbiote sinister six
right so like basically spider-man
versus venom and then like some of the
sinister six roster that we're familiar
with but they all have venom symbiotes
that would be amazing imagine like a
venomized doctor octopus like a
venomized green goblin although
technically green goblin did become
carnage in the comics so like the red
goblin as he was called and like a
venomized version of like craven the
hunter or like electro although that
probably wouldn't work because the
symbiotes don't respond well to
electricity and fire regardless it'd be
cool to see that kind of a thing right
it'd be cool to see that that whole
scenario play out that's pretty
far-fetched but those are the kind of
ideas that could potentially come to
fruition so i'm down with andy circus's
idea that they kind of want to hold off
on spider-man versus venom and give us
some more stories involving some of the
villains that exist out there in the
spider-man mythos that can really kind
of expand this whole landscape now on
our second piece of news here i know a
lot of you guys were huge fans of marvel
zombies dare i say here that the marvel
zombies episode was probably the most
anticipated episode of what if because
it was so different that's one of the
things that i've learned over my time in
just watching you all when it comes to
your reactions on social media with
anything related to comic books comic
book movies especially when i was
running comics explained you guys loved
things that were just different right
like hey guys here's a story where the
incredible hulk fights wolverine huh
cool i'll watch it you know in that
video i'll do a hundred thousand views
hey guys here's a story where the
incredible hulk kills all the
superheroes and becomes the herald of
galactus
three million views like that right you
guys love just the weird and wonky
stories when it comes to stuff and for
the casual movie going audience that's
familiar and loves the marvel cinematic
universe up to this point
zombies sound amazing
so it was a really really cool concept
well in light of that comic book creator
mark miller who was technically the
first to introduce marvel zombies in the
ultimate fantastic four comics although
robert kirkman the guy who wrote the
walking dead he was the one to actually
write the standalone marvel zombies
series or at least the good ones anyway
mark miller came out and said that there
is potentially a live-action marvel
zombies project in the work now to be
honest with you guys i feel like this
was kind of coming
ever since the possibility of marvel
zombies and what if popped up on social
media as soon as that hit everybody was
talking about it i would go as far as to
say it was the one thing everybody was
talking about right and people were
talking about like chadwick boseman
reprising his role as black panther
being able to hear him again everybody
celebrating that eric killmonger tony
stark teaming up the possibilities on
what we might see in the show agent
carter but i think far and away the
talking point for the what if series was
marvel zombies it's the one thing
everybody wanted to see and i think
based on the popularity of just general
social media reaction somebody somewhere
at marvel studios it's kind of like hey
maybe we should kick around the idea of
a possible live-action marvel zombies
thing let's wait and see how the episode
pans out see how people respond to it
and if there's a huge thing where
everybody loves it then we can kind of
put some feelers out there and just sort
of see where things go well if any of
this is true because again mark miller
is kind of like hey it's a possibility
right i mean he came out and said if my
sources are correct there's a potential
project in the works it would make sense
that they would do this right a live
action marvel zombies show or
potentially even a movie would be really
really amazing it'd be really exciting
to see because there's a lot of history
there to cover now if you guys want to
know more about marvel zombies
particularly how the whole thing
unfolded i've got the full story video
over on comics explained which is
essentially all the marvel zombies stuff
just packed into one video
so hopefully that would be something you
guys are interested in uh but i am
excited at the prospect of a live action
marvel zombie show i just hope they
don't amc that show right you guys know
what i mean like the walking dead was
great until like season five and then it
just got bad friend of mine had a theory
once and said no show should really last
any more than five seasons because after
that all the shows really just kind of
start dropping off which makes sense
dexter
so before we get into our last little
tidbit of news here
about vincent d'onofrio playing kingpin
in hawkeye
[Music]
let's talk about some gaming stuff so
vista chess who is really a reddit user
has actually been going through and
recreating the entire star wars universe
galaxy in minecraft now brandon
minecraft is not a universal simulator
right so you can't travel from one
planet to the other in minecraft so
presumably he's just creating different
worlds each one representing a major
world from star wars but it's an
enormous undertaking now we will post a
link to his youtube channel down in the
description he's only got a couple
videos each one's like two minutes long
so not a whole lot to go on there vista
chess you want to blow up on youtube man
make your videos longer than 10 minutes
and upload three times a week you
already got the topic covered everybody
loves minecraft and your projects are
cool just let the algorithm take care of
the rest but a bulk of what they've
shown is actually available on reddit so
we'll go ahead and post a link to the
reddit post that highlights a lot of the
stuff that they're creating but overall
it looks amazing i mean i know that that
minecraft is known for just these insane
undertakings right the kind of things
people have done on minecraft in world
building is really just uh it's nothing
short of just astounding the amount of
work they put in i mean people have
recreated entire cities so like paris
france new york city people have
recreated theme parks so like disney
world disneyland with all the rides that
work in their entirety i mean just it's
astounding the kind of effort that
people put in i want to say there's a
person who recreated the entire death
star from episode 4
in minecraft which is crazy like all the
decks and everything work which is kind
of nuts but it's cool to see people
undertaking these just enormous tasks
right somebody sits down somewhere and
says i want to do this the amount of
time dedication and effort it takes
especially because this person's a
one-man team they don't have a whole
bunch of people working on it it's just
them it's incredible that kind of
dedication is just really something to
to be astounded by but we figured we'd
share that with you all because while
it's not the biggest piece of news ever
i think it really highlights the kind of
cool things that we as people are
capable of when it comes to playing the
games we love
but on our next piece of news here the
next call of duty game coming out in
2022 which normally we wouldn't cover
this but i'm going to cover it because
it's my favorite call of duty game of
all time modern warfare 2. ironically
enough modern warfare 2 is my favorite
game of all time black ops 1 was the
game that i broke out in right where i
was getting like four five six seven kds
like almost every game like it was nuts
i was so good at black ops 2. i'm i'm
gonna straight up brag here right i'm
gonna straight up brag and be like i was
legit in black ops one right i was very
very good in black ops one but modern
warfare two was my favorite game it was
the call of duty game that got me into
multiplayer never played cod 4
multiplayer but i loved the era of
modern warfare 2 right it was it was so
fantastic everybody talks about the
whole the whole mission of like no
russian like when they shoot up an
airport i don't care about that i care
about the multiplayer man do you guys
remember the early glitches right where
you could run around with the javelin
and if somebody killed you everybody
died when you had the care package
glitch so if you had like the care
package grenade in your hand you could
just run super fast so like in the early
days of pod four you'd go on to capture
the flag somebody would get like a care
package and then like they would take it
out so they could throw it they'd
capture the flag and just haul ass back
to their point
it was almost impossible to catch them
after that it was cool right i know a
lot of you guys who are call of duty
fans most likely grew up in that era of
modern warfare 2. the youtube community
was amazing kind of but not really
because there were a lot of people who
caused drama but nonetheless i'm excited
to see what this remake is going to be
like and on the topic of remakes we know
we have remakes like alan wake coming
out they're removing all the product
placement which is awesome what are we
going to get remakes of like dino crisis
or like parasite eve i loved parasite
eve
what are we gonna get remakes of these
games because honestly i know a lot of
people seem to be in a kind of fit of
rage about the idea that like remakes
are coming out as opposed to genuinely
new ips or just getting like dlc for
like gta 5 instead of getting gta 6 but
honestly a lot of these games that are
being remade from the 1990s this
nostalgia feels for me right so i'd give
a pass
i'd give a pass to this and i say hey
it's remakes and remasters of games that
i grew up with with modern day graphics
i'm really excited to see what those
games look like i'm really really hyped
for it alan wake is probably one of my
favorite games of all time so i'm
excited to see what that game looks like
but i'm curious leave a comment down
below if you could have any game from
your youth remade on modern day next gen
consoles with modern day graphics which
game would you pick but having said that
let's get into our final piece of news
here vincent d'onofrio as the kingpin
now vincent d'onofrio is one of these
really interesting characters right when
it comes to his kind of reveal of the
fact that he's doing stuff he's always
been super cryptic over the years
vincent d'onofrio would never deny
something but he would never confirm
something he would always just kind of
leave these tweets out there that it's
like hey guys i'm returning for
daredevil but i'm not but possibly i am
do you think i should i don't know i
guess you'll have to wait and see to
find out it was never any definitive
answer
right it's like asking a person the
question and all they do is answer your
question with another question right
like hey vincent d'onofrio are you going
to play kingpin and hawkeye well i don't
know do you think i am that's basically
what it turns into right now the reason
why this has garnered so much attention
recently is because vincent afrio has
kind of gone through and just started
liking a whole bunch of tweets related
to hawkeye and while that doesn't really
confirm anything the fact that he hasn't
really had any involvement in the mcu up
to this point and the fact that he
hasn't really seemed to show any
particular favoritism towards any of the
mcu projects until hawkeye has caught a
lot of people's attention especially
because we don't really know who the
main villain is going to be we know that
hawkeye has basically walked away from
his role in the avengers we know he's
training kate bishop to become the new
hawkeye kate bishop's untrained untested
really seems to have raw talent which
means they're not going to be facing off
against gigantic threats they're likely
going to be facing off against more
homegrown threats and if that's the case
i can't think of a better person to pick
than vincent d'onofrio's kingpin he's
got the forces he's got the the
wherewithal he's got the ability to take
on someone like hawkeye right just his
physical stature is enough that he's
just an imposing guy and a lot of people
have been wanting to see vincent
d'onofrio return as kingpin in the mcu
now truth to tell if vincent offio was
going to come back i would prefer that
he come back as either a character in
the spider-man movies or
as a villain facing off against
daredevil is kind of a re-launched
remade
sequel whatever it is to the netflix
daredevil shows but having said that i
don't mind seeing vince dinoviou return
his kingpin in any form or fashion
because let's be honest with ourselves
guys let's just let's just nod our heads
and say yes rob you're correct vincent
d'onofrio as kingpin was amazing he was
so awesome i left his speech at the end
of daredevil where he's like i am the
ill intent i love that whole thing right
it was so cool i love that concept for
his character and the reality is no one
could have played the kingpin better
than him and to have him return in the
mcu would just kind of go towards the
idea that all's kind of feeling right
with the marvel cinematic universe world
so again let me know what you guys think
about vincent d'onofrio potentially
coming back actually returning its
kingpin it's the first real indication
we've seen from anybody that it could
actually be happening so it makes sense
that fans would be super hyped up about
it but let me know what you guys think
well that being said we're going to
bring this episode to an end again
fingers crossed we don't miss out on any
insane news between now and sunday and
we will catch you all later
peace peace
peace
double piece